(audience applause)
Is it true that your kids weren't allowed to watch TV
but then, maybe during the pandemic, that changed?
Yeah, yeah things obviously changed
for everyone during the pandemic
and I just never had a TV, I was always outside,
mountain climbing, skateboarding, my mom just got me out
so, and my wife didn't really, you know,
she wasn't having the TV around, she was just working
so I think when we met we never had one
and when we raised the kids,
we'd watch little movies here and there
but no, they're big into reading and getting outdoors
and so now I embraced it, and we're watching Netflix
and I saw Stranger Things, and the kids wanted to watch it,
and man, it was awesome.
(audience laughing)
So then we went down the rabbit hole of like, okay.
But it was just beautiful family time,
cuddled up, just two babies under my arm
and I got excited just to watch it,
I mean, we miss mamma so we started watching Cosbys
and man, just watching that whole, you know,
just seeing her when she was little
and the babies getting to see her and it was phenomenal.
What did your kids think when they saw their mom on Cosby?
They just, I mean, Lola 100% just fell in love,
like she just, she watches it still.
So she just loves it.
Wolfy's definitely more into action stuff,
and so we've been slowly introducing some of mine
but my stuff's pretty, not kid appropriate so,
they don't really, I don't know,
they've went everywhere with us, you know,
even when I did Game of Thrones and I'm covered in blood,
you know, Lola's just sitting there knitting in the corner,
I'm like, hi baby, and I'm just like,
ripping people's throats out
and she just, you're just being silly, papa, so.
(Drew laughing)
I love it, Khal Drogo, come on,
it's the greatest thing in the world.
You literally changed the world,
that's all we all talked about for months, years,
was you and Khaleesi, that's it,
that was like, as if there was nothing else to talk about
but Khal and Khaleesi, that's it.
It was a fun show, thank you.
Now, Jason, we have had such a pleasure speaking with you
today, your insights about life, family, the world, humanity
and everything that we're capable of have been so inspiring
and I was wondering if we could play a little game with you?
Sure.
Um, Momoa in a Minute.
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)
(clock ticking)
Okay, I'm gonna fire off some questions your way
and you'll have a quick minute to answer them,
are you ready?
Oh gosh, yes.
Okay, number one, what's your worst habit?
What's my worst habit?
(Drew laughing)
Always on time.
Oh god, I'm always, oh god.
(audience cheers)
(Drew laughing)
All right, who was your first celebrity crush?
Lisa Bonet.
I knew it, I knew it, okay, biggest aphrodisiac?
Oysters, all you need, all you need.
Oh, guilty pleasure.
Guilty pleasure.
Um, I ride motorcycles that involve gas and oil,
which I'm trying to steer away to e,
guilty pleasure, I love riding motorcycles.
Absolutely that goes as a guilty pleasure.
Boxers or briefs?
Boxer briefs.
Oh, sensible.
(audience laughing)
Last text you sent.
Last text I sent?
To my daughter and my son, it's under, the babies.
I love you, I'm gonna be on Drew Barrymore right now.
(audience applause)
Oh, I'm in your last text.
You're in my last text.
Okay, excuse me, biggest regret?
Oh, I don't do that.
Good.
I made the choice, I don't regret I just.
God.
Sorry.
No, good, I'm, again, I'm like, okay gosh, okay.
Oh, um, what do you smell like?
Campfire,
geeze, probably gasoline, oil,
and Hawaiian flowers, there you go.
(audience laughing)
Hence the new aphrodisiac, ladies and gentlemen.
Age of your first kiss.
Age of my first kiss, Jesus Drew.
(Drew laughing)
Probably 12, gosh my kids are 12,
no, push it later, 14.
I know, by the way, no it's so.
14, Lola and Wolf.
14, 15 take your time, take your time.
Oh god, try going to Studio 54 at seven
and telling your kids to go to school.
The last time you cried.
Last time I cried?
Oh, last week, I cry a lot.
Enough already with you.
Okay, have you ever eaten anything off the floor?
Oh yeah.
(Drew laughing)
Look at me.
I have, too.
Jason, I don't know where to begin,
but let this never end, our lovefest with you, really.
Nah, you were amazing, thank you, Drew.
Thank you for setting our show up
on the right path in every sense of the word.
The real Aquaman, we all love you so much, Jason.
Mananalu Water is available online
and select West Coast retailers, of course.
And thank you, you're the exact superhero we need
in movies and in real life.
Doesn't work if you don't recycle it,
so that's just as important.
It's going in the recycle and thank you so much.
(upbeat music)